[Musique]
est ce que tu te rappelles ce monsieur
je commets pas s'appelle michel le caire
je te le dis on a retrouvé ce faire bah
on va voir si souviens de toi
et parce que michel le caire c'est ont
pissé dans les trousses aussi quand
j'étais collé à bas j'ai des petits
flashs qui reviennent michel
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur michel c
je crois vous étiez l'ancien directeur
de l'école
est-ce que vous soulevez de booba abouba
monsieur booba je me souviens très bien
mais tu te souviens tu vois par exemple
un beat it jouer dans la cour de l'école
à la récré que tu te soumets avec qui tu
jouais je me souviens d'un
un présumé portugais qui avait au moins
50 plus que moi je traînais avec un
vietnamien s'appelait gérard j'allais
manger des soupes chinoises
alexandre hollan dares
ça fait 34 ans il était du blond ou
est-ce qu'il était sage bas monsieur a
créé un petit ange
ouais toujours poli et puis c'est aussi
toujours le premier à lever la main pour
répondre aux questions mais je me
souviens vue ils seront avec moi
est ce que tu te souviens la cantine tué
mais les fruits chez la vache qui rit
dans les poches
je rentrais chez moi les poches coller
la maison gueule presque à tuer mais
rappelle toi tu es mais les pêches
à tel point que tu en étais dans tes
poches pour les ramener pour les manger
à la maison cellulaire mais est ce que
c'est pour cette raison c'est un acteur
sport est-ce que c'est par cette règle
que tu as gardé comme principe de vie
genre de la pêche
[Rires]
[Musique]
bref vous avez préparé une surprise pour
booba oui tout à fait vous avez un peu
de musique
aujourd'hui l'on m'a dit alors c'est pas
bien le 15,6 me disait on avait dit
50000 vue je crois qu'on a atteint voilà
je crois qu'on a pas 48000 franchement
on va dire que c'est bon on a déjà un
petit peu tard est-ce qu'on peut montrer
s'il vous plaît le sait comme les
chiffres du cogat studio les studios un
studio boulade
si chez toi maintenant ici bravo